all right and here he is as promised the
six-time pro bowler
from that stout new orleans saints
defense that thanks to the offense
having a ridiculous time of possession
afternoon hardly broke a sweat
and beating the chicago bears am i right
cameron jordan hardly broke a sweat
right
i mean you know you always break so when
you're going against you know
a kid who gets that ball out as fast as
mitch did last night
but when you talk about how our defense
is able to play you know i think they
only had a couple
third down completions you know i i i
mean don't mark me if i'm wrong but
i think our our secondary playing lights
out in our interior line do they thing
up front
well obviously i introduced you with
tongue fully planted and chic but uh uh
let let us hit that though what is it
like
um as a defense that has been rolling
as you have been rolling all season long
to see
plays in the second half uh that are
being put on
together by your offense drives of 12
plays 15 plays 11 plays
only seven and a half minutes of
offensive possession time for the bears
in the second half what is that like for
you
on the sideline cam it gets cold
it's cold
and yet you know you must get a little
cold out there right but i know honestly
it's so it's so amazing to watch them
work you know you talk about
um the whole squad really being healthy
um
with mike t aka emmanuel sanders you
know little jordan got loose
you know we jared cook turned it up i
mean there was there was just so many
different factors in this game
uh the officer off the line played you
know
played well today or yesterday um and
just
how they were able to get the job done
of course you have drew going for drew i
mean
you doing drew like things i'm still i'm
still perplexed on how we didn't get 28
points on the board we drew on the one
yard line
um right that's erroneous to to us
winning the game right now
yeah it is i mean look it was really
clicking in so many different ways and
you point out again that
that the offense was at full strength
with michael thomas back in alvin kamara
thank god healthy and and everything
that that that we're able to see
emmanuel
sanders making a great catch and holding
onto the ball it's just
really all working what what happened on
the defensive side of the ball
after that one and two start that's
caused you guys to just be
truly lights out uh from here on out
what's
what happened did anything click
anything happen
cam no not at all i mean you know the
world seemed to be
you know on our shoulders before we were
we were ready to uh
to really say that hey we have some
troubles i mean you go one and two
in our in our building we've gone oh and
203 oh and you know whatever it is
uh we we knew the people that we have in
the locker room we knew that
you know with our leadership with our or
our playmakers in in building
that we were going to be all right um
and we're more than all right we you
know we're going into
the second second round of the playoffs
and we have
you know we have our destiny in our
hands
and it just seems to me that uh
everything is in fact working and
clicking have you
experienced anything like this in your
tenure you played on some great defenses
where does this one rank for you
cameron um i'll figure that out when
uh you know after win the super bowl uh
that's what we're here for we're here to
make a super bowl run
and i can't rake this defense until the
job is done
cameron jordan here on the rich eisen
show okay
so you you were talking about you know
trubisky getting the ball out
quickly and just to put i guess your
trust levels
paparazzi hat on for a moment before i
return you to being a six-time pro
bowler getting ready for
uh tom brady and and the buccaneers
much of a conversation well much of a
conversation will be about trubisky and
his quarterback skills
where does he rank for you in
quarterbacks that you got ready for this
season do you think he is a
threatening quarterback in the nfl
can i play the fan
i guess yes you
i think that he has long developed since
the first time i played him
when he only threw for like 11 passes
and i remember the 11 passes because it
was that impressive
um to go through a whole 60 place script
with that many passes so he's come a
long way
yes and that's where you'll end the
sentence or
you is there anything else no no that's
where i'm going to end it
okay that's where we'll end it very good
cameron jordan here on the rich eisen
show
let's turn let's turn the page now to
tom brady then
uh who's uh at uh let's just say a
different end of the spectrum
um here uh now the last time
you guys faced him was the last time you
came on this show
uh when you got back from tampa after
putting an absolute
beat down on the buccaneers and that
offense
have you seen the how this buccaneers
offense
has been performing lately i assume
you're you're going to have your hands
more full than the last time you saw
them
would you assume that or no i don't know
how much more full of a person's hands
can be because you know they've had
gronkowski antonio brown mike evans
chris godwin
um at this point you know leonard
fournette shady mccoy
tom brady uh and then of course you can
go to the defensive side of the ball
where they have you know
uh shaq bear jpp uh
i think devante white's going to be back
up levante david i mean they've got
they've got uh names and talent
all across their roster um so the first
second time i mean
you know how hard it is to be an
individual opponent let alone
individual part twice let alone to have
to face the third time
um it's uh it's something that we've
done before you know
just not against tampa so cool
i'm looking forward to how much they're
going to be in their bag i mean this is
tom brady we're talking about
this is top two quarterbacks of all time
you know
uh luckily we have the not and if he's
you know
the top two he's not two in our building
i know i know that
i know you've said that before not a
battle ahead of us so what uh
let's i want to i want to get get a
little bit more out of what you say
you're
you're excited about how much they're
going to be in their bag what do you
mean by that
i mean you know the last time we played
uh we'll probably forever leave a mark
on
on their mind uh coming into our dome
again
uh you know what the score was 38 to
three yep it was yeah so i mean
you know you know it's going to be
screaming revenge you could probably you
started that up as soon as they as soon
as they beat the uh
the washington football team um that
they were screaming that for revenge
season or whatever it is
but we have to play our best ball to to
get this game i mean
um when i say they're gonna be in the
back they're gonna you know they're
gonna throw things that we haven't
seen before they're gonna you know try
and analyze what we what what happened
to them the first time as well as what
happened to them the second time
to try and prevent what we would like to
happen the third time
um you know they've got a phenomenal
team and again this is something that
they've already been to our dome except
now that yeah i think we had more fans
left you know yesterday than we did
this entire uh season combined almost i
mean it seemed like our stadium was loud
loud enough
um hopefully that's back to i mean it's
not the same standards
of of the last 10 years i've been or
nine years i've been part team
but for this year being in in uh covert
season
there was a lot of fans and there's a
lot of noise in there and you know
that's something that
uh can can help our defense we we feed
off that energy even though we bring our
own
yeah the last time they were there was
week one when everybody was just trying
to figure out
what the hell was it going to be like
playing in a pandemic season that was
that was the home opener for you that
was the season opener
for brady and then obviously the last
time you faced them it was 38-3 just
eight yards rushing cam jordan here on
the rich eisen show
uh i know you've got a lot more um gray
in your beard and a lot more pelts on
the wall than chase young has but can i
can i get you to say that
bring on tom brady like chase young good
can i get you to say that
i will say that uh we we
took took on the tom brady challenge two
times in full
and now that we have to face them a
third time that brings uh even more
problems that we have to solve
within this next couple days and i'm
looking forward to the challenge you are
a grizzled veteran
cameron jordan grizzly actually we're
all giving a round of applause right
here on the rich eisen show well done
golf club
very very well done very very well done
um so
your coach got slimed uh i noticed that
um
i saw that i did an interview right
after the game was when the nickelodeon
kids and i was like yo this linebacker
comes out i'm taking off
i'm like i don't you know you can always
wash your hair or wash your clothes
but i didn't want slime in the pants so
luckily that didn't happen to me i saw
i saw sean had his his uh his his retro
11 load
days on you hate to see a good pair of
j's go cause these those are done you
can't clean those
you sure don't need a probably done
there's no there's no way
for for those shoes to be cleaned or
anything like that huh
not at all i think that slime is gonna
be in there like that's it looks
you know yeah that goop is that goop is
probably never leaving but then again
you know you you can say hey i've been
trying before
you can't say that well certainly since
you've b since you beat
uh uh you said you won a playoff game in
that respect i was watching the game
uh the first half on the nickelodeon uh
feed with my kids
and it was just fascinating to me to see
all that and it was it was fun to be
honest with you i know you've got kids
did you did you um did you interview
with them beforehand tell them your
favorite ice cream and things like that
cameron did you did you have to provide
all that information
prior to this product i i think yeah i
think we did that in building uh okay
you know
covet cover doesn't eliminate a lot of
the uh
um how do you say that a lot of a lot of
the the interviews that you normally
would do you you sort of get away from
it it's
been a positive you're just gonna focus
straight on football i'm not gonna lie
to you it's been nice
well i don't know if you're aware either
cameron uh but um
again these are these are small young
children impressionable
young children that i'm going to give
you an opportunity to maybe express
um how they need to um pay a little bit
more heed to the action maybe uh rather
than maybe a popularity contest but
mitchell trubisky won the nvp award the
nickelodeon
valuable player update award he won the
voting
uh 49 percent uh akeem hicks 16
and then cameron jordan eight percent
you you you bronze medaled
in the first ever nvp voting do you have
something that you'd like to
to say to the to the uh young lads and
lasses that voted in this
camera always tried to be first i
believe uh uh a phenomenal
uh philosopher one said if you're not
first year left
okay so you know
keep striving for number one i guess
okay i guess so all right cameron
look there's always room to improve
right i guess last serious question got
twice the score i did
he did that's what i'm saying he did get
twice
what are we what are we basing this off
akeem is my dog i mean he's a monster in
the middle
yes what are we doing i got to be better
than that he doubled you up but trubisky
won it all at 49 percent of the vote
percentage of the vote of the
mvp i mean i can't fight the trubisky
thing there's probably a lot of memes
from his first quarter throws to his
fourth quarter throws i mean you know
how it started how it's going is what
you're saying yeah
you are the best man oh my gosh uh
last question before you uh go and in
all seriousness here
um the way that your last three post
seasons ended the fact that you got a w
means what uh it means our job is not
yet done
we've got to focus on on this game and
this game's gonna be huge
because it's not you know it's not just
we we face them once or
twice this will be our third time um and
this everybody knows how hard it is get
a win in this league
especially when you talk about playoffs
the lights shine the brightest so
it means nothing unless we get this win
and then two more wins okay
i love it that's why you're the co-host
of the trust levels podcast you and
ingram right so
so that's done correct you you're in the
can if you will for the rest of the
season it's over
for the pod hey exactly we're we're
focused we're locked in and you know
until until i get to get the shot to be
in tampa bay
twice because now cam vegas come to new
orleans twice
look at that interesting all right
cameron well good luck with that i
always appreciate
our conversations uh and i love watching
you play so thanks for the time
i appreciate it always rich thanks for
having me you got it same to you that's
cam
jordan cam jordan 94 on both twitter and
instagram
from the wild card week and victorious
new orleans saints
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here